here we have our droppers and they
contain our urine sample we use the
droppers that came with the pregnancy
test to withdrawal the urine in this top
dropper
we have urine that contains HCG and how
I know that is because it's my urine and
I'm pregnant
this bottom dropper contains urine that
does not have HCG in it it comes from my
husband so he shouldn't have HCG in his
urine so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna add three drops of urine to each
test so add to this top one this is the
urine that has the HCG so 1 2 3 and then
wad drop here 1 2 3 and we're gonna let
that go for 3 minutes cuz for this
particular test they say to wait 3
minutes to read the results but don't
read the results after 5 minutes because
they won't be valid
you
so it's been three minutes now we're
going to interpret our results so as you
can see here in these tests we have a
line in both of the control areas this
tells us we added enough urine and that
this test is working however in this
pregnancy test here on the top there is
a line in the test area so it's positive
which tells us that it detected HCG in
the urine however here on the bottom
this bottom pregnancy test there is no
line in this test area so it is negative
it tells us that it did not detect HCG
in that urine sample